topic of today's speech is Obamacare's
assault on religious liberty it's an
important subject and we're grateful to
the Philip and McKenna foundation for
making possible this lecture it's part
of a monthly series first principles on
First Fridays
it focuses on timely matters all rooted
in a constitutional understanding of our
republic this day we're very grateful to
have join us a distinguished professor
of history from Hillsdale College Paul
Ray has taught at Hillsdale College
since 2007 I have a couple of his books
and what to make mention of them before
he is formally introduced the first of
them is something that really takes two
hands to lift Republic's ancient and
modern this in its first edition it's
since been published in two volumes and
is available from the University of
North Carolina press it's a tour de
force I'd recommend it to you all there
are a number of other books all of which
are available online copies of which are
also in the the the lobby for your
viewing but one that I'll mentioned to
you in particular is soft despotism
democracies drift the subtitle of that
book by Professor Ray Montesquieu
Rousseau Tocqueville and the modern
prospect he's working currently on a
book on Sparta teaches courses in a wide
range of subjects at the college and
also blogs regularly about which more in
a minute to introduce our speaker this
morning is Hillsdale College junior
Alexander Milne ickle a native of
Michigan he's participating in the
Washington Hillsdale internship program
where he's interning as an American
Studies major fittingly at the Capitol
Hill Historical Society Alex
good afternoon Paul a ray holds the
Charles Olli and Louise Cayley chair in
western heritage and his professor of
history at Hillsdale College he earned
his PhD from Yale University and has
taught at Cornell University and the
University of Tulsa he blogs on ricochet
comm and has authored several books
including soft despotism democracies
drift and Republic's ancient and modern
classical republicanism and the ancient
and the American Revolution today dr.
ray will be speaking on the topic
Obamacare assault on religious liberty
please join me in welcoming dr. Paul Ray
by the way my favorite review of this
book began with you've heard of a book
that you can't put down I'm reviewing a
book you can't pick up my topic today is
has as its focused the Health and Human
Services mandate which President Barack
Obama announced in late January when he
announced that mandate michael barone in
the Washington Examiner who's a close
friend of mine wrote a piece in which he
suggested that the president was living
in a bubble and that his proposal of
this mandate and a men of other things
that he'd done suggest a certain
ignorant and isolation simply that he
wasn't talking with enough people we
know a bit more now we know that the
President did not act on impulse that he
took his time in making the decision and
that he sought advice from a range of
individuals within his own party Vice
President Joe Biden and William Daley
who was then Obama's chief of staff both
professed to be Catholic and they
strongly advised against doing anything
that when I antagonize the Catholic
Bishops and the Catholic lady Kathleen
Sebelius Secretary of Health and Human
Services and Nancy Pelosi the former
Speaker of the House and the current
Democratic minority leader in the house
were also consulted they too professed
to be Catholic and they fiercely
advocated imposing this board burden on
all employers providing health insurance
for their employees the decision appears
to have been made before the New
Hampshire primary otherwise it would be
hard to explain why at the debate in New
Hampshire in early January George
Stephanopoulos who pretends to be a
journalist but is still obviously
nothing more than Adam
kradic operative which doesn't
distinguish him from most journalists
repeatedly pressed MIT Romney to spell
out where he stood on the question of
contraception and poor Mitt Romney was
asking this question over and over again
in various forms he doesn't have a clue
as to what's going on why is this
subject being raised well it's being
raised in anticipation of what the
president is about to do and
Stephanopoulos is operating operating
not as a reporter but as an operative
Stephanopoulos is disgraceful
performance which drew boos and cat
calls from the crowd when they begin to
figure out what was going on is an
indication that Obama and at least some
of his aides thought that they had
something to gain by injecting this
question into this year's electoral
campaign now what makes this all the
more shocking is that last November
November 2011 President Obama summoned
Archbishop Timothy Dolan of New York who
was President of the United States
Conference of Catholic Bishops
to a meeting in the White House to
reassure him that nothing of the sort
would be done
James Toronto The Wall Street Journal
reports that at the end of their meeting
Archbishop Dolan said this to the
president I've heard you say mr.
president first of all that you have
immense regard for the work of the
Catholic Church in health care education
and charity I have heard you say that
you are not going to let the
administration do anything to impede
that work and that you take the
protection of the rights of conscience
with the utmost seriousness does that
accurately sum up our conversation and
Archbishop Dolan reports mr. Obama said
you bet it does the archbishop asked for
permission to relay the message to the
other bishops you don't have my
permission you've got my request the
president replied so you can imagine the
chagrin Archbishop Dolan continued in
his interview with James Toronto when he
called me at the end of January to say
that the mandates remain in place
and that there would be no substantive
change and that the only thing that he
could offer me was that we would have
until August I said mr. president I
appreciate the call are you saying that
we have until August to introduce to you
continual concerns that might trigger a
substantive mitigation in the mandates
he said no the mandates remain we're
more or less giving you this time to
find out how you're going to be able to
comply Dolan replied well sir I don't
need the extra time I can tell you we
are unable to comply the administration
then went ahead and announced the
mandate the same day a public backlash
ensued and the archbishop got another
call from the president on the 10th of
February he said you will be happy to
hear religious institutions do not have
to pay for this that the burden will be
on insurers Archbishop Dolan asked if
the president was seeking his input and
he was told the modified policy was a
fait accompli the call came at 9:30 in
the morning the president announced the
purported accommodation at 12:15 p.m.
that same day now on the face of it
President Obama would appear to be
shooting himself in the foot why would
he risk losing the Catholic vote in the
November 2012 election when could of
course argue that his aim was to excite
the feminists and give them a reason to
turnout in November as a rationale
however this seems a bit lame the
benefit that the president proposes to
provide is insubstantial to be sure the
administration's initial claim to the
contrary notwithstanding the pill and
other birth control devices are not free
but the expense involved is not great
among those who are employed and have
health care insurance no one is hard put
to come up with the paltry sum required
this suggests that there can only be one
reason why Kathleen Sebelius Nancy
Pelosi and Barack Obama decided to
proceed they wanted to show the bishops
and the Catholic lady who is boss they
wanted to make those who think
contraception wrong
and abortion a species of murder
complicit in both they wanted to rub the
noses of their opponents in it they
wanted to marginalize them humiliation
was in fact their only aim and malice
their only motive later when in response
to the fierce resistance he had
deliberately stirred up the president
offered the bishops what he called an
accommodation what he proffered was
nothing more than a fig leaf his
maneuver in fact was a gesture of
contempt and it was Barack Obama's final
offer from his perspective and from that
of Sibelius and Pelosi the genuine
Catholics still within the Democratic
coalition are no more than what Vladimir
Lenin called useful idiots and now that
the progressive project is near
completion they're expendable for
there's no longer any need to curry
their favor let me emphasize the
substance of this all the talk is about
contraception but this is not really
about contraception because included in
the HHS mandate is the morning-after
pill in the morning after pill is
without any question and abortive
fashioned so what this is is a stalking
horse for making Catholic hospitals and
Catholic insurers pay for abortion free
of charge and of course those health
insurers will pass on the cost to the
people who are paying for the health
insurance leave aside the fig-leaf
the aim then is to make this election in
part a referendum on the sexual
revolution and all of its consequences
which explains why they wheeled out
sandra fluke an unmarried middle-aged
law student at Georgetown University
slated on average to make $160,000 per
year in her first year after graduation
that's the average received by
Georgetown law students when they get
hired by law firms they will they're out
as a poster girl for the new policy to
complain that it costs her an
unsustainable three thousand dollars a
year to pay for her own contraception
now three thousand dollars a year
is an awful lot but let's suppose that
it's true
that's what she would wake in her first
week after graduation you see from the
perspective of this administration
premarital sex is essential to the
health of all unmarried women if you're
not getting it you're gonna go down and
they clearly believe that by stirring up
this controversy they can deflect
attention from the state of the economy
from the national deficit and when the
election President Obama's intervention
in the dispute over the shooting of
Trayvon Martin by George Zimmerman is
part and parcel of the same strategy to
win he believes that all that he needs
to do is to stir up the fears and
hostility harbored by sexually single
sexually active women and by
african-americans and he may be right
the polling data suggests that there is
a radical divide between
african-americans and all other
Americans on the way that they read the
trayvon martin george zimmerman case and
the recent polls suggests that there is
a radical divide that has emerged
between men and women
with regard to the upcoming presidential
contests i say they suggest this because
there's only really been one poll and we
will see there is of course more at
stake and the president knows it free is
not merely interested in his own
reelection he's in fact willing to risk
his reelection to achieve the ends he
wants to achieve he is also interested
in shutting down civil society and he
hails from a city where they really know
how to do it to this end his attorney
general sought to assert the right of
the federal government to oversee the
hiring and firing of religious teachers
by the evangelical lutheran church and
fortunately for us the United States
Supreme Court was unanimous in rejecting
that claim unanimous meaning the two
women appointed to the court by Barack
Obama voted to reject the assertion of
his Attorney General that's astonishing
to this end his administration has
considered the means by which the
government can use its licensing power
to intimidate radio station owners into
shutting down conservative talk radio we
get the second term I think we will see
the FCC moving in this direction to this
end the president sought to have
corporations seeking government
contracts list their political donations
now in Chicago we know what that means
and we know what that would mean in the
United States Barack Obama is from
Chicago he understands how a political
machine can isolate intimidate and crush
all sources of opposition so we should
not kid ourselves about the stakes the
Evangelical Lutheran Church in the
hosanna-tabor case and the Catholic
Church in its struggle against the HHS
mandate are like the canary in the coal
mine
religious freedom is the root of modern
Liberty crush the former and you can
easily crush the latter when James
Madison drafted what became the first
amendment to the Constitution he knew
what he was up to
it reads Congress shall make no law
respecting an establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof
or abridging the freedom of speech or of
the press or the right of the people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
the government for a redress of
grievances note the things that are
mixed up together they're mixed up
together because they belong together it
is no accident that John Locke the
Englishman who penned the letter
concerning toleration was the man
responsible in his guise as a civil
servant for England's abandonment of the
licensing of the press intellectual
freedom political freedom and religious
liberty have always in modern times been
inseparable there's another perhaps
better way to make the same
point limited-government is a modern
phenomenon the ancient Greek city did
not have a limited government it had a
government that was in principle total
in principle ancient Athens and ancient
Sparta were totalitarian the same is
true of ancient Rome the same is true of
all of the medieval monarchies and of
the medieval Republic's in principle in
practice of course their capacity to
extend their power was limited because
they did not have the technocratic means
to do so
think what the computer and the Internet
allows the government to know about your
tastes and your preferences and how you
conduct your affairs and what you like
to look at we should not kid ourselves
about the effect of technology in
increasing the potential power of
governments to superintend our lives in
the most precise manner but limited
government as I said as a modern
phenomenon it was crafted in the late
17th century to solve an otherwise
apparently insuperable problem
the catastrophic political consequences
of the fact as visible in late antiquity
especially in the Christian East as it
would be in the Christian West during
and after the Reformation that the
Christian faith tends to give rise to
doctrinal disputes and sectarian
divisions only if these can somehow be
quarantined John Locke and others
thought only if doctrinal disputes can
be kept out of the political arena
only if political Authority can be made
neutral with regard to sectarian
divisions can there be domestic
tranquillity within Christendom and to
this end he proposed that government
beery conceived that it be refounded on
the basis of an imagined social contract
that it be limited to the protection of
the rights accorded human beings
by nature that is to say to the rights
that no one in his right mind would even
think of alienating first and foremost
the right to life liberty and property
which is the formulation that you will
find in the Declaration of Rights that
George Mason wrote for the Virginia
Constitution in the Declaration of
Rights that John Adams wrote for the
Massachusetts Constitution which is the
formulation that John the Thomas
Jefferson rephrased when he spoke of
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness in the American Declaration of
Independence
it is not fortuitous that this same
Thomas Jefferson asserted the existence
of religious liberty as a natural right
in the Virginia statute of religious
liberty moreover when he substituted the
pursuit of happiness for John Locke's
property he did not mean to deny that we
have a natural right to the fruits of
our own labors nor did he mean to make
property rights dependent on positive
law as some suppose in the revisal to
the laws of Virginia that he penned in
1779 three years after the Declaration
of Independence he restates John Locke's
trilogy verbatim life liberty and
property when he substituted the pursuit
of happiness for property Thomas
Jefferson did not mean to eliminate
property from the list what he was
looking for was something more extensive
of which property and its acquisition
and preservation would be an example
something for which the acquisition of
property might be a means something that
included religious faith for Jews for
Christians and for Muslims as Jefferson
well knew the free exercise of religion
is part and parcel of the pursuit of
happiness indeed for those who are pious
in a serious manner it is the most
important part of the pursuit of
happiness
now I be labor this point on I be labor
it for a reason I be labor it because I
believe that when Barack Obama's
stated in 2008 that he wanted to
fundamentally change in the United
States and he when he called his
administration the new foundation he
meant precisely what he said he meant he
wanted at the basis at the foundations
to transform this country what did that
mean it means he wants to repeal the
Declaration of Independence
it has rightly been said that Obamacare
changes the relationship between the
citizen and the government radically the
h h mandate is the canary in the coal
mine because it is made that fact
manifest and I hope that its issuance
serves as a warning to the American
Catholic Church I say this because that
church has mightily contributed to
placing in the hands of Barack Obama the
power he is now wielding against the
Catholic Church in the United States for
decades now the Catholic Church has been
allied with the left in domestic affairs
pushing for ever more extensive and ever
more expensive social programs for
decades the Catholic Church has been
pushing for one form or another of
universal health care demanding as its
first priority that the federal
government enact a health care policy
that quote and I'm quoting from the
website of the United States Conference
of Catholic Bishops that ensures access
to quality affordable life-giving health
care for all in the process the bishops
asserted on the 27th of January 2010
that health care is a basic human right
and they claimed that nearly 50 million
Americans do not have access to health
care I will come back to that claim
which is a bald-faced lie
but I would submit that no such policy
can be enacted without concentrating
tyrannical power in the hands of the
government I would submit that the
social teaching of the Catholic Church
as it has been applied in the United
States by the American Catholic Bishops
is inconsistent with the principles of
limited government and then in rejecting
the principles of limited government the
American Catholic Church has rejected
the foundations of religious liberty the
bishops have been hoisted on their own
petard
they contributed mightily to fashioning
the weapon now being wielded against
them let me be more precise consider the
Declaration of Independence and the
inalienable natural rights mentioned
therein consider the Virginia statute of
religious freedom and its defense of
religious liberty as a natural right the
rights specified in these two documents
both drafted by the same man have this
in common they are negative rights in
each case it is the task of the
government to defend us against those
who would interfere with our exercise of
those rights who would deprive us of
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness as we conceive of that
happiness which is where both the
acquisition and preservation of property
and religious liberty come into it we
are to be constrained by this government
only to the extent that we deprive our
fellow citizens of life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness and it is our duty
to cooperate with the government in
protecting those rights that is what
constitutes justice under a limited
government there is another conception
of Rights it asserts that it is a
responsibility of the government to
guarantee to all Americans a set of
positive rights rights that it will
exercise on their behalf on the 11th of
January 1944 in a State of the Union
message Franklin Delano Roosevelt
delimited what he called an economic
Bill of Rights here is when he said we
cannot be content no matter how high our
general standard of living may be if
some fraction of our people whether it
be one-third or one-fifth or one-tenth
is ill fed ill clothed ill housed and
insecure the Republic had its beginning
and grew to its present strength under
the protection of certain inalienable
political rights among them the right of
free speech free press free worship
trial by jury freedom from unreasonable
searches and seizures
they were our rights to life in Liberty
as our nation has grown in size and
stature however as our industrial
economy has expanded these political
rights proved inadequate to assure us
equality in the pursuit of happiness now
I want you to notice something because I
want to pause for a second the
Declaration of Independence does not
assure us equality in the pursuit of
happiness what it ensures is that our
pursuit of happiness will not be
interfered with think about what is
required to ensure equality in the
pursuit of happiness 40% of American
children are born out of wedlock they're
not going to have equality in the
pursuit of happiness unless we ensure
that all American children are born out
of wedlock you cannot bring them up you
can only bring the rest of the country
down to assure equality in the pursuit
of happiness which is a utopian notion
requires a totalitarian government it
requires a government that interferes in
every little aspect of life so there is
a new idea here the New Deal was a new
foundation the New Deal was a repeal of
the Declaration of Independence but let
me go on in our day these economic
truths have become as accepted as
self-evident we have accepted so to
speak a second Bill of Rights under
which a new basis for security and
prosperity can be established for all
regardless of station race or creed
among these are the right to a useful
and remunerative job in industries or
shops or farms or minds of the nation
the right to earn enough to provide
adequate food and clothing and
recreation the right of every farmer to
raise and sell his products at a return
which will give him and his family a
decent living the right of every
businessman large and small to trade in
an atmosphere of freedom from unfair
competition and domination by monopolies
at home or
rhod the right of every family to a
decent home the right to adequate
medical care and the opportunity to
achieve and enjoy good health the right
to adequate protection from economic
fears of old age sickness accident and
unemployment the right to a good
education all these rights spells
security and after this war is talking
about world war two is one we must be
prepared to move forward in the
inflammation implementation of these
rights to new goals of human happiness
and well-being here's the problem
accepting this economic Bill of Rights
requires a massive shift of
responsibility from the individual the
family and a local community to the
central government accepting it requires
a massive shift of power from the
individual the family and the local
community to that government under the
old dispensation it was the
responsibility the individual citizens
to provide for themselves to find jobs
to negotiate adequate salaries to find
markets for what they produce to locate
niches where their work would be
rewarded to find decent housing and pay
for it to arrange for medical services
to lay money aside for old age sickness
accident and unemployment and to seek an
education suited to their abilities and
their needs and this they did as best
they could with the help of their
families their friends and their local
communities under the new dispensation
this was to be the job of the federal
government and to fulfill this
responsibility that government was to
take from those inclined to provide for
themselves in order to provide for those
not so inclined to take the fruits of
one man's labor in order to support
another man it is no accident that when
Franklin Delano Roosevelt spoke of
certain inalienable political rights
he left property off the list nowhere
does he assert that a man has the right
to the fruit of his own Labor's and he
doesn't believe it herein lies a problem
in the absence of secure property rights
none of the other natural rights
mentioned in the Virginia and
Massachusetts Declaration of Rights in
the Declaration of indepen
and in the Virginia statute of religious
freedom can be secured for property is
power it is by means of the fruits of
our labor that we pursue happiness it is
by means of the fruits of our labor
that we secure freedom from domination
it is moreover by means of the property
that we have earned that we are able to
pursue happiness insofar as it can be
pursued in this world a government that
provides jobs specifies salary
guarantees markets provides niches
wherein we can work guarantees housing
arranges for medical care provides for
our old age sickness accident and
unemployment and provides for our
education cannot but be a government in
control of our lives such a government
will be sorely tempted to decide how how
long we shall live and when she we shall
die and there is provision for that
within Obamacare Sarah Palin spoke of
death panels that is what they are such
a government will be sorely tempted to
commandeer our lives and subject us to
its regimen it will tell us what kind of
light bulbs we can use it will tell us
the shape of the toilets we use and if
we are inclined to overeat it will tell
us how much we can eat it will dictate
to restaurants the fat content of the
food that we eat it will intrude into
our lives in the most ridiculous of ways
and it is already doing so such a
government will also be sorely tempted
to define for us how we are to pursue
happiness and woe be unto any secular
organization synagogue temple mosque or
church that stands in its way when the
American Catholic Church embraced FDR's
economic Bill of Rights as it did long
ago when it demanded that the government
ensure access to quality affordable
life-giving healthcare for all it put it
swell
it's liberties and frankly ours in the
hands of men who will be and are sorely
tempted to do it and us harm in 1936 at
the Democratic National Convention
Franklin Delano Roosevelt charged that
American Liberty was in danger that a
small group of economic Royalists was
intent on concentrating into their own
hands and almost con treat complete
control over other people's property
other people's money other people's
labor other people's lives what he said
was a demagogic lie there was no such
conspiracy but today something of the
sort really is true as the American
bishops are in the process of learning
the hard way thanks in part to their own
efforts a small group of technocratic
Royalists is now not only intent on
concentrating into their owns hands and
almost complete control over other
people's property other people's money
other people's labor other people's
lives they've almost achieved that end
much much more could be said but your
time is short and so is mine there are
however two further points that need to
be made the American church heard
gravely when it waded into the political
arena it muddied the waters and it
compromised its moral authority the
American bishops have no special
political or economic expertise indeed
in economic matters they are no more
expert and generally tend to be far less
expert than the laity for them to
pronounce on these matters is for them
to risk making fools of themselves and
this reduces the likelihood that they
will be listened to when they pronounce
on questions of faith and moral morals
where they have a legitimate claim to
Authority two days ago I spent hours
waiting through the website of the
United States Conference of Catholic
Bishops what is striking about it is the
fact that one cannot in surveying it
distinguish which pronounces brown
Smiths on public policy follow from
church doctrine and which are mere
potential judgments reflective of the
fallible opinions a particular clergyman
let me say is the frequent flyer and
mask o'er in a great diversity of venues
that the same thing pertains to sermons
and Here I am being generous the truth
is that in recent decades one heard next
to nothing from the pulpit in the
ordinary parish concerning contraception
abortion sterilization and the like the
silence of the Catholic Church spoke
very loudly when rarely if ever heard
the word chastity mentioned and one
never never heard the concept defended
and word one heard the political
opinions of clergymen ad nauseam father
John Newhouse was right when he said
that the classic clergy are not obliged
are obliged not to speak about political
matters when they're not obliged to
speak about them they have no special
expertise and they abuse their office
when from the pulpit they speak of these
matters they abuse that office in
similar fashion when they failed to
address the pressing moral issues of the
time at a moment when 40% of all
children born in the United States are
born out of wedlock it is long past time
for Roman Catholic priests to explain
the teaching of their church and the
grounds of that teaching concerning
chastity the second point that needs
making is that embracing FDR's economic
Bill of Rights the Catholic Church has
in another fashion done untold harm to
itself and the same can be said of the
Catholic Church in Europe it is worth
asking how human beings coped
before the welfare state was invented by
Bismarck and introduced in the United
States by Franklin Delano Roosevelt
what did Americans do before Social
Security what did they do before
Medicare what did they do before
Medicaid I could go on the list is long
the answer is simple they look to their
families for help in times of need
and with that in mind guess what they
had families
they look to their churches and to that
end guess what they attended church
gunnar myrdal the Swedish Social
Democrat who wrote the American dilemma
gave a set of lectures at Harvard in
1944 their theme was simple and
straightforward the long-term effect on
mores and manners of the social
insurance scheme would be he believed
demographic decline 1944 he predicted
this people married and had children for
many reasons out of a sense of joy out
of a sense of moral and religious duty
out of a lack of self-control and with
an eye to their long-term interests
children were their social security they
were a source of labor in the shop or on
the farm and when one got old one could
look to them for support when the state
steps in mere doll worn Ornt it subverts
the family it reduces the incentives for
having children
it turns what was once an investment in
one's own future into a very great
financial burden it produces a situation
in which prospective parents repeatedly
ask themselves how many children can we
afford and if you've not asked that
question of yourself it's because you're
not a parent I speak as the father of
four and if nothing is done in a
compensatory manner married all warned
people will have fewer and fewer
children he said it would take time for
more ease and manners to change in light
of the shift in incentives but they
would change in the long run he
predicted the social democratic state is
apt to eat its seed corn for there will
not be enough people in the younger
generation in the labor force to pay for
the social benefits promised to the old
what he foresaw is the world in which we
live one in which we have made promises
we cannot keep to those who have paid
into Social Security and Medicare for
decades to those receiving Medicaid to
civil servants promised gold-plated
pensions but
there is more the HH mandate has to do
with contraception and the morning-after
pill which is to say abortion it is part
and parcel of the sexual revolution and
the presumption underpinning that is
that celebration of sex purely as a form
of entertainment the underpinning of it
is a radical divorce between sexual love
and procreation the ethos of sexual
gymnastics which is almost all pervasive
in this country now think of the
popularity of sex in the city how else
can you explain it is a product of the
administrative entitlement state once
the welfare state is in place the family
loses its privacy and lovemaking and
procreation come to be divorced and once
they are divorced there's no compelling
reason to marry at all I say this as
someone who travels I used to go to
Montreal every year Montreal and Quebec
was a center of Catholicism in North
America I can remember going to Mass in
a church over by the old city
there were 26 confessionals in that
church it was Sunday morning at 10:00
there were six of us in the congregation
it's gone
and guess what in Quebec nobody gets
married anymore and by the way the same
thing is true in France and if you
travel in Europe try going to an
Anglican Church sometime in England on
Sunday morning I've been in Anglican
churches where the choir which was paid
outnumber the congregation go to
Scandinavia to Lutheran churches they
might as well be museums once the
welfare is state is in place the family
and let me add the church loses its
primacy there is an intimate connection
between the American Catholic Church's
articulation of the universal Church is
social teaching in terms of FDR's
economic Bill of Rights and the HHS
mandate and there's a close connection
between the welfare state that it has
embraced and the decline in the United
States of the Roman Catholic Church its
position on these questions is suicidal
and if you want to see where the suicide
has already been accomplished go to
Europe and go to Catholic churches in
Germany in France in Spain and in
Ireland and ask yourself how did this
happen thank you very much
questions this gentleman here if you can
take him there are also questions I
believe coming over the Internet and
there's someone here who may act on
behalf of the folks on the Internet yes
thank you sir
very much appreciate your your reasoning
and I'm a fan of identifying that our
lack of what I found is what I call
piety I'm also very concerned that we
need to get back and we don't
necessarily need to get back to my faith
or his faith or hers which are happening
happily very similar but we need to get
back to piety and what the founders knew
is piety where they all got into a room
in Philadelphia and left their religions
at the door and came in with their faith
in their prayer and joined together and
did a wonderful thing how do we get back
there sir well it has to begin with the
churches that exist it has to begin with
an abandonment of the notion that the
minister or the priest is like a tour
leader on a on a voyage across the
Atlantic whose task it is to make
everybody in the pews happy the happy
talk has to end
in other words Christianity is a
demanding religion and you will not have
a full-blooded return unless you have a
return on the part of the clergy to
their responsibilities now I actually
think that this may be on its way it is
certainly a profound concern of the
current Pope who has spoken to groups of
American bishops in the firmest possible
way about this question it seems to be a
concern of Archbishop Cardinal
Archbishop Dolan as he now is because if
you look at this
interview he did with James Toronto in
The Wall Street Journal about ten days
ago he talks about the failure to talk
about the crucial issues
I mean look let's not kid ourselves
what's in our people American
churchgoers most likely to commit it
would strike me sins of the flesh come
very high on the list the very sins that
don't get mentioned and this is
systematic and it goes back to a problem
that erupted in the Dodge Diocese of
Washington in the 1960s with priests who
were refusing to support the church on
the contraception issue an archbishop
who bravely confronted them and then the
ground was cut in from under him I think
you're gonna see a reversal of that I
can only speak about the Catholic Church
I don't often attend services elsewhere
but I will say this there is a deep
hunger for people who actually address
the issues that we face I'll tell you a
story there was a priest not so long ago
I was filling in for another priest in a
and he was a young guy in a parish and
he decided since it wasn't his own
parish and he wasn't going to suffer the
consequences that he was going to speak
on contraception
and when he left the pulpit and walked
back to sit down for the offertory
he thought he was going to hear boos he
got a standing ovation he got a standing
ovation so it seems to me that there are
people ready to listen
furthermore there's a much larger public
that would actually come to church if
these issues were firmly frankly
addressed
gentleman over there take it from one
side than the other
words are important and the definition
of a tyrant as I understand is is
someone who operates without regard to
Constitution or established law does our
current president meet this definition
and if so why isn't he called what he is
I'll start at the end well he doesn't
meet this definition and he's not called
what he is because we Americans are very
sensitive about race we have reason to
be sensitive about race our conduct in
the past was not the best and I'm being
generous to us when I use that language
the consequence is we are all inclined
to bend over backwards with regard to
this particular president things he can
get away with things other people can't
get away with now I am personally not
inclined to hold back with regard to
criticizing what he's doing let's face
it he's a bully he tried to believe the
Supreme Court within the last week his
aim is to bully the Roman Catholic
Church Eric Holder operating on his
behalf
tried to bully the Evangelical Lutheran
Church he deliberately stirs up racial
animosity he is unscrupulous he learned
his politics in Chicago and he learned
his politics on the radical left and the
combination is toxic
I can not answer your question better
than that next we have a question from
our online audience Josh asks can you
comment on the constitutionality of the
HHS mandate if Obamacare is
unconstitutional which it surely is does
that also invalidate the HHS mandate
I think if Obamacare were declared
unconstitutional if the individual
mandate not the HHS mandate but the
individual mandate were declared
unconstitutional they'd have to take out
the whole bill and with that would go
the power of the health the Department
of Health and Human Services to impose
such a mandate now that having been said
there is another question which perhaps
that particular question was aimed at is
the H HHS mandate HHS not only to ages
in contravention of the First Amendment
to the Constitution that's a more
complicated question because it depends
on how broad you take the Free Exercise
Clause to be so let me pose a question
back does free exercise include setting
should we tolerate women committing
suicide Hindu women committing suicide
on the graves of their husbands does
free exercise include polygamy where do
the limits lie does free exercise
include refusing to do military service
to take an issue that goes back in
American history to the time of the
founding let me suggest that the Bill of
Rights is not primarily intended to turn
political questions into judicial
questions it's primarily meant to shape
public opinion and to cause congressmen
to think twice before they do certain
things I do not for example believe that
in light of the original understanding
of the Constitution the Free Exercise
Clause includes the right to refuse
military service I'll tell you why the
social contract is built upon
cooperating with one another in defense
of one another's lives liberty and
property National Defense is absolutely
central to that but from the air very
earliest years of the Republic when this
question came up legislators exercised
legislative grace and displayed a
species of generosity to Quakers and
Mennonites and others who were
conscientious objectors it strikes me
that Congress should have displayed that
generosity to Roman Catholics you know
particularly liked the idea of being
complicit in murder other question
gentlemen over here
I was gonna say I wish you told us how
you really thought I'm notorious for
exercising self-restraint
however a serious question other than
the religious resurgence you have
mentioned what do you see as a sectarian
plan of action to work on the problem so
you've identified
I'm sorry sectarian what do you mean
exactly you mean secular secular secular
uh well it strikes me that Barack Obama
is a kind of gift to conservatives he
thinks he has a gift you've got to
remember you know his eloquence got to
remember that gift is the German word
for poisoned
he's a gift in the following way he has
unmasked the administrative entitlement
state he has made its tyrannical impulse
the tyrannical impulse lying behind it
visible when he attacked the Roman
Catholic Church he did the Roman
Catholic Church a great favor because he
forced it to face up to the consequences
of the direction that it had been moving
for decades when he took money away from
Medicare to fund Obamacare he caused old
people to wake up and realize how much
how dependent they had become upon the
kindness of strangers and how that
kindness of strangers could quickly turn
to cruelty when he embedded rationing in
Obamacare that is to say there would be
a panel that would decide that at your
age it's really not worth spending money
on the cancer that you have he made
people afraid outside the religious
sphere when he tanked the Supreme Court
he caused people to wonder about the
separation of powers when he made
appointments ignoring the fact that the
Senate was still in session
and showed contempt for the Senate and
the Constitution he made people nervous
the consequence is he is opened up a
possibility for a political candidate if
he had the courage in the wit to
actually address these questions
globally and to show how they all fit
together
the media is not quite as powerful as it
once was
consider what NBC tried to do to George
Zimmerman and consider how quickly
people on the Internet
caught on to the fact that they had
doctored the tape to make a man who had
displayed no hint of racism look like a
racist they get caught now they get
exposed now I really feel they are
shameless they go on and on but you know
when you lie to people over and over
again they stop watching you the New
York Times is not as powerful as it once
was
NBC is not very powerful anymore CNN
what is it the least watch cable news
network show they have earned their
place now you know they're gonna go to
the wall they're going to distort
everything they possibly can but enough
people are awake to this but I think
things could change if we have a
candidate who has the courage and the
wit to address these questions in terms
of first principles any other questions
well he indicated that the Obama
administration attempted to marginalize
and humiliate the leadership of the
Catholic Church and I wonder about the
motivation and the timing of this
because you also indicated in your
presentation the church actually on
social policy had largely been
supportive really of the Obama
administration in the last election he
got most of the Catholic vote and with
an upcoming election what was the
motivation for doing something like this
now rather than waiting until after the
election and securing the votes in
support of the Catholics again I think
the answer is getting reelected is not
his first priority
look there is something impressive about
the man what he wants is a mandate to do
the things he wants to do now you don't
get a mandate by avoiding issues you get
a mandate by addressing the issue
head-on and getting two people to vote
up or down on you in light of that issue
so what he has done is he has embraced
the sexual revolution he has embraced a
strategy laid out for him by two
professing Catholics Kathleen Sebelius
and Nancy Pelosi and I can tell you what
they told him and it's half true what
they've told him is Catholics won't back
up their bishops on this question and
what they told him is a fair number the
bishops will be with you in their hearts
and look the Catholic Health Association
has backed Barack Obama the sisters of
mercy has backed Obama the Jesuit organ
America has editorialized in favor of
Obama and against Cardinal Doland the
association of Catholic colleges has
backed Barack Obama object excuse me of
Jesuit colleges has backed Barack Obama
he knows
but Catholics are divided over this
question he knows that for 44 years now
catholic bishops and priests have shied
away from talking about conception
since the compromise of 1968 here in
washington DC he thinks he can run a
truck over those bishops then he'll have
them where he wants them you know look
why would he do the key why would he
refuse the building of the Keystone
pipeline the answer is he wants to stir
up the radical environmentalists he
thinks if you put the radical
environmentalists together with the
feminists together with African
Americans together with whatever you can
put together a majority and you can win
and you can decide things in such a
fashion that they will never be
revisited again now I have to think he's
wrong look in the Casey decision of the
United States Supreme Court they thought
let us put abortion to rest and they
called on everybody to shut up that it
was over that was a while ago it's not
over it's not ever going to be over so
there's a calculation here I happen to
think it's the wrong calculation and he
did it in this route away as possible he
made promises in November in January he
dropped them and he showed he's really
good at showing contempt
I mean if look in the early days he
humiliated the Prime Minister of Britain
when he came to visit in the first few
weeks he he released a picture of him
talking with Netanyahu of Israel in
which he's got his feet up and what
you're seeing other the soles of his
feet which in the Arab world is a sign
of contempt these things are deliberate
that picture was released by the White
House he knows what he's doing in this
regard
and he comes from a background in
Chicago community organizing Saul
Alinsky in which the trick of the game
is to demonize your enemy and to
intimidate your enemy and then reduce
them look in Europe the Italian fascists
invented this technique here's how they
dealt with their enemies they caught
them on the street and they fed them
castor oil do you know what happens if
you drink a lot of castor oil I won't go
into it not in a public place ask me in
private if you want to know now what
does it do it reduces you to a kind of
blubbering mass intimidate demonize
terrified get him under your control
that's that's what he does habitually
and look he comes from Chicago and there
hasn't been a free election in Chicago
in my lifetime and there never will be
until the Chicago machine is rolled up
in imprisoned any other questions we
have a second question all right Alice
axe your recent posts on ricochet
regarding Catholicism have been
outstanding
they caused me to wonder though whether
you see the religious rites influence on
politics dwindling or increasing in the
immediate future the answer is I don't
know it ought to be the case that what
Barack Obama has done with regard to the
Catholic Church would cause Catholics to
unify and vote him out and if they were
to do so it would have a big impact
consider what would happen if Hispanics
in California were to rally against him
not necessarily against the Democratic
Party forever but against him in this
election that depends on the moral
authority of the bishops
and that depends on the willingness of
individual bishops to throw themselves
into this fight that depends on how many
bishops are secretly with the sisters of
mercy and the Catholic Health
Association and I don't know the answer
to that question that some are I haven't
the slightest doubt so it all depends my
hope is that Barack Obama in his
arrogance is in the process of causing
serious rethinking of a Catholic
Church's commitment to the welfare state
there is within the social teaching of
the Catholic Church a foundation for
rejecting the welfare state
it's called subsidiarity there's a big
emphasis in the Catholic social teaching
going back maybe not to rerum Novarum
but to Quadra JC Milano forty years
after rerum de varam was stated and
subsidiarity means everything that can
be decided and dealt with on the local
level ought to be dealt with and decided
on the local level and that local level
goes all the way down to the family now
that require a lot of thinking and I'm
afraid thinking takes place slowly
people really well people don't like to
rethink and you know we have the saying
it's very hard to teach an old dog new
tricks well it's very hard to teach an
old bishop new tricks too
but this ought to be shocking to every
bishop and priests and nun in the
country and when you shock people
sometimes they sit back and they say
wait a second
what have I been doing and what are the
consequences of what I've been doing any
other questions yes sir
this will be our final question I thank
you for your moderate description of the
president which would be radicalized if
one read his autobiography first one
which is very revealing but which
virtually no one talked about in any
serious way and then a minor footnote is
that the Catholic Church just around the
corner
st. Joseph's has an excellent new head
pastor very outspoken on abortion a fact
which is is getting him into trouble
there I understand but father Avellino
Gonzalez's an excellent we have a new
priest who's very outspoken
the only he's married a new priest is
fabulous this this let me say one thing
about in response to that it's not
actually an answer to anything um
there's another sign of hope and I left
it out the Catholic Church has gone
through a great crisis the crisis had to
do with the question of sexual predators
among the priesthood it's something that
has led to considerable rethinking in
all sorts of quarters you can see this
in the remarks of cardinal Dolan in the
Wall Street Journal ten days ago he
touches on this voluntarily he wasn't
pressed to but he brings it up and he
was right to bring it up the second
thing is there has been a wandering out
of the Catholic Church and the people
who are left are actually more
conscientious than the ones who wandered
out and the new priests the younger
priests now there's some places which
have no younger priests let me give you
an example of how bad it is the state of
Maine there are 10 priests in the state
of Maine under the age of 50 that's how
bad it is in some places there are other
places Lincoln Nebraska where the
doesn't suppress export in other words
where they actually preached the gospel
guess what people want to be priests who
wants to be a tour guide on a cruise
ship who would you know who would choose
celibacy as the price for being a tour
guide on a cruise ship but to actually
make the argument to have that
opportunity that attracts spirited
people so in general I think the younger
priests are a great source of hope and
there are older priests who because of
the younger priests have gotten a new
life I know some of these priests and
they speak of it in those terms maybe
the church in America will become a
church militants thank you very much
thank you very much professor ray and
before we adjourn let me say just a
couple of quick announcements you know
it's sometimes said that in polite
company you should not conjoin the two
topics of religion in politics
we've just flagrantly violated that but
done so yet with with a real attention
to deliberative and and a thoughtful
conversation and to that we're grateful
professor ray in fact whenever I've
heard that that that idea I thought well
what else is there worth talking about
we'll continue on in the theme of non
controversial subjects next time looking
at race relations in America with a
speaker yet to be determined
but that is may Friday May the 4th this
series will continue today we invite you
all to join us for lunch lunch is served
downstairs and I think the the rain is
holding it base or you're welcome to go
up to the fourth floor eat outside you
might want to make sure everything is
batten down there's some wind but
otherwise you're welcome to take a tour
around the building if you'd like us to
tell you more about hills dales presence
here in the nation's capitol
we'd be happy to do so and if you have
any questions for any of the Kirby
Center staff you can find us throughout
the building thank you very much for
coming today